in the reset process
the important thing is gratitude
so you cannot forgive a thing or an
event or a person or even forgive
yourself
until you find gratitude for the bad
thing
and this is the thing that's missing
from a lot of forgiveness literature
because in your in your automated like
operating system your ability to hold a
grudge and be grateful you cannot do it
so that tiny spark of gratitude is the
thing that starts the fire of
forgiveness and then forgiveness is
something you do and it's a feeling in
your heart and it's a specific brainwave
and I'm using the tech to guide you into
the right State and it's similar to a
thing you can do with a therapist called
EMDR where they'll also love embr okay
me too EMDR is powerful not anyone
listening if you have a trauma that you
know about you can go to EMDR and it'll
be better in like one or two sessions
yeah you know it it's not the same as as
the reset process but the similarity
with the MDR is you go into the state of
like ah like that was icky but there's
another state that's the opposite of
that and when the body says wait I
cannot possibly have been as much of a
threat as I thought I was because I I
just experienced this exalted spiritual
state of heart openness and beauty and
and I just experienced gratitude so then
it realizes
my programming was wrong I had the wrong
threat detection system let me just
erase that and when it's erased it's
actually gone yeah I look at it almost
like time travel it's like it is time
travel back to the time and you
reprogram the event
and he does a ton of personal
development work Danica you're
interesting like it is that but most
people don't say it's time travel
um but yeah you you go back and your
body doesn't really know about time
because it's a bunch of dumb bacteria in
there anyway so they don't know and
here's the weird thing when someone does
those five days of if it's like just
deep it's meant to replace Decades of
meditation in five days which is why I
keep using it as an example because it's
and I can see the numbers
um
when they're done they're like oh my God
I am so different this is amazing but
then six weeks later it's like yeah it
wasn't it was awesome it it made it made
a difference you know I still remember
it was really good but I feel like I'm
myself again and then you ask their
spouse or their friends like are you
kidding me like you're a completely
different person
but already what's going on is it it was
just you but more you and your memory of
every event once you do a forgiveness
process your memory is no longer
emotionally charged so that's why that
CIA guy could look at me and go yeah I
was tortured because he done his
forgiveness work yeah there's two things
that really are just irritating and one
of them is worrying right like I'm gonna
play this potential story of the future
over and over and the thing about
worrying is it's coming from those
ancient mitochondria programmed to look
for that threat but the more they look
for it the more they find it so worrying
is provably bad for your outcomes it
it's manifesting in a negative way so
you got to learn how to shut down the
voice in your head and I had all the
critical voices and worrying voices and
and all that I did enough you know
shamanic training and meditating in the
Andes and Himalayas and you know
Ayahuasca and Peru in the 90s when you
know they actually told me that yeah
that's ahead of the curve well they
actually I was asking around and they're
like you're white I'm like yeah I know
but that's only for local people I said
look no I've done my research I really
have come here and I'm choosing to do
this and they found a shaman for me and
all
um but yeah that was before it was a
tourism thing and uh I actually think
it's it's a little bit dangerous to do
it without the right supervision oh it's
always dangerous to do yeah division um
they're safer medicines out there
um like anyway not to get diverged there
I was like safer medicines like
um oh like almost any of the other
psychedelics
um so do you want okay do you want to
know like the order of Opera buttons for
Altered States work for trauma healing I
would love it okay
I gave this as a talk I was with a group
of really highly successful people
looking at
um extreme longevity which has been an
area of focus for me for for a long time
and one of the guys I got up and said
you know I have done 50 plant Journeys
this year
and it's been life-changing and you
should all do this too I'm like there's
two billionaires in the audience here
right these are people who control
masses of jobs and and to a large extent
they control some of the future because
if you're a billionaire and you're like
I'm gonna put 500 million dollars into
destruction of soil or saving of soil it
actually matters a lot more than my 32
acre regenerative farm right like like
that they're moving the needle
so I said I Gotta Give a talk after this
I said guys I I've tried these things
I've done the trauma healing work so
here's what you do
okay step one
do some breath work
just knew you were going to say breath
work and meditation and if you're not
getting there fast enough okay step two
uh maybe you should try EMDR which we
talked about just a minute ago because
it's really fast right and if that
doesn't work then let's go lightweight
try some MDA and which is different than
MDMA it's without the meth part of MDMA
so MDA is more heart opening and less
stimulating than MDMA and if that
doesn't work do MDMA
and if that doesn't work do ketamine
which is very safe and I'm saying do
this with a therapist I did one of my
podcast episodes I went I got injected
with ketamine at a uh at a psychiatrist
Clinic just to you know talk about what
it does and to experience it
and if you're still not getting there
Academy is very powerful for forgiveness
I would call it the Forgiveness Mall
because really good for forgiveness so
you you and then okay like still out
there with ketamine all right well then
maybe you could try
LSD
and if it's not there okay mushrooms
problem with mushrooms is you don't know
what you're going to get there's you
know 100 different kinds of mushrooms
picked from different sources and they
um
outwards some you know some are really
strong some aren't as much I agree I
love mushrooms depending on which ones I
get and so I just don't like the
variance there
um and when it comes to plant molecules
like that
um there's also like energetics like was
it picked under a full moon was it
picked by like a very angry person I
think it matters and so do the shamans
who have taught me these things so
um I just I don't like the variance
there but LSD is relatively stable if
it's actually LSD then it does what it
does because it's a synthetic molecule
yeah and then after mushrooms
and then you would look at doing DMT
then 5meo DMT oh yeah I've heard about
that I don't know much about the five
Meo one and they're relatively similar
um but the Mia is a little bit stronger
and if you still haven't got there then
you hop on an airplane
you fly to Peru
or maybe Ecuador or somewhere where
there's someone who has taken
Ayahuasca on a daily basis
for decades
and then they put you in a ring of
stones and do a bunch of incantations
and have you eat a special diet for a
little while and then they do the real
deal because I remember when I did
Ayahuasca the one time I did I've been
called to do it since then
um I I went down there and said okay
look I'm fine and and the person I was
doing it with also it was throwing up
and everything and he'd given me a
triple dose uh but I just I process I
didn't throw up I said I'm gonna go for
a walk like I and he goes no you can't
and I'm like look yeah I can touch my
nose I am not high it wasn't hitting you
right no it did hit me I I had my
experience but I was just done with my
experience and so this was after it I
definitely had gone and visited stuff
um
and I said I am totally okay I just want
to like walk and he said do you see the
Ring of stones and I said yeah he said
those stones are there to keep things
out
because you are still open and if you go
outside that ring of stones I will have
to remove all the things that are going
to stick to you and that's a lot of work
and I don't want to do that that's a
real Shaman the job of a shaman in a
plant medicine ceremony with that
substance is to keep all the bad malware
out of your system that can enter which
is why I recommend more caution with
Ayahuasca than I would with any of the
other things in that order of operations
oh I forgot the one after breathwork
meditation MDR
tantric sex you should do that before
you start going oh that one I had to
cross that one off the list there you go
about 20 of people it will report in
surveys of like having profound
religious experiences during orgasm and
their partner just sees them twitching
and having a good time but they're
meeting God so yeah yeah I agree I mean
that's a what a cool like hierarchy list
and you're totally right like Ayahuasca
has become so much more mainstream and
there are some dark people targeting
famous and Rich and powerful people with
Ayahuasca and I don't think that that's
always clean sometimes it is but there's
there's some stuff I don't I don't
always like there but there's also some
good stuff happening yeah yeah well
all I can think of is literally coming
home like in the middle of a ceremony
two nights second night midnight wake up
we gotta pack our bags and leave because
the borders shutting down in the morning
oh wow that was how session that was how
night two ended that's a big wake up
[Music]